ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANT
AT ARMS WILL REPAIR THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN
IRAN BELA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRAVO.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERONE CORREO SURVIVED SAYS
CHILD SHAUNA THEN IS CHEN. DAVID
CHIU. CHOI KANSEN CHU. COOLEY
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
LARA. FONG.
FRAZIER READ MEN. GALLAGHER
CHRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEVINE MAY
MOAN. LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MIRTH SU CHI NECESARIA EN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAISES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SOLACE SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE.
THERE MEN'S
TEEN BOTH PAL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOULD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE WILL.
MEMBERS OF QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL GRANT
UNANIMOUS CONSENT FOR MR HOLDING
HAVE GUESTS OVER TALKERS ON THE
FLOOR AND AT THE ROSTRUM FOR
TODAY'S OBSERVANCE OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR HOLIDAY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR BUT CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
THE DAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY A GUEST CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND BRANDON A DOCTOR
BRANDON FISSURES THE PASTOR
KYLE'S TEMPLE AFRICAN METHODIST
EPISCOPAL ZION CHURCH HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
PASTOR FISHER.
LET US PRAY.
OUR FATHER.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE GIFT OF
ANOTHER DAY.
AS WE GATHER TODAY.
WE CELEBRATE AND COMMEMORATE THE
LIFE OF DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR.
I PRAY THAT HE WILL HELP US THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE HIS LEGACY.
HELP US TO REMEMBER THAT WE HOLD
THESE TRUTHS TO BE SELF EVIDENT.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
THAT THEY ARE ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR.
WITH CERTAIN UNALIENABLE RIGHTS.
THAT AMONG THESE ARE LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
REGARDLESS OF GENDER.
RACE
CLASS RELIGION ETHNICITY OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
YOU HAVE TOLD US THROUGH THE
PROFIT MICHAEL.
WHAT IS REQUIRED OF US?
TO DO JUSTICE
AND TO LOVE KINDNESS.
AND TO WALK HUMBLY WITH OUR GOD.
TODAY MAY WE ENDEAVOR TO DO
JUSTICE.
TODAY MAY WE IN THERE ENDEAVOR
TO BE KIND TO ONE ANOTHER.
TODAY.
MAY WE ENDEAVOR TO WALK HUMBLY.
BLESSED PERSON ASSEMBLED HERE
TODAY.
THAT WE WILL DO WHAT IS RIGHT
AND JUST. TO HELP THE PEOPLE WE
HAVE BEEN CALLED TO SERVE.
A MAN.
THANK YOU PASTOR.
I WOULD REQUEST THAT OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS. AND MEMBERS REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
TODAY WE WILL ASK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER TO LEAD US IN THE
PLEDGE.
PUT YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY DECEMBER
FIFTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN PERCENT
OF THE PROVISIONS OF DRECK ALL
FIFTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
HE RAISED R. THAT OUR ROOM AND
MISTER MOVES AND MISTER DALI
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION IN
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DIM RED AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
I THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
MR CALDERA MISTER CALDERON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED HERE MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COOPER. MELENDEZ
IN PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON.
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH OBD
ORDER THEY KI?M AND SPEAKER
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS
SPEND JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
HEAR AB STATE SIXTY FIVE THE
BEAM. TODAY UPON A GERMAN
OBSESSION IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
HERE.
THIS WALDRON WE OBJECT AND ASK
FOR ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MS WALDRON OBJECTS
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MISTER
GIBSON SECONDS THAT THE RULES BE
SUSPENDED IS NOT DEBATABLE
MCCORKLE OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR IN AYE
VOTE MISC
WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A NOBLE.
MR CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE.
MOTION BY MISTER.
WE HAVE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROPE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS NINETEEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THE MOTION CARRIES MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO SOMEONE WILL NINETY SEVEN ARE
QUESTION ANIMUS CONSENSUAL RIVER
FOR FILE ITEM NINETY THREE. AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX KALRA TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THE BILL WAS
ERRONEOUSLY REPORTED TO THE
FLOOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
WILL BE THE ORDER MISTER
CALDERON.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ITS IN THE WILL FIFTY
SIX TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE HR SIX YEAH
COMING AT ALL. FOR THEIR JANUARY
SEVENTEEN HEARING PENDING RIP
REFERRAL PENDING REFERRAL FROM
THE RULES COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH WILL BE THE
ORDER.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE STRIKE THE VETO
MESSAGES FROM THE FILE. THESE
ARE ITEMS NUMBER FIVE THROUGH
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A BEAUTY
ORDER.
WE'RE MOVING TO GAS
INTRODUCTIONS
MISTER PATTERSON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER OP.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. BUT DEANNA ALAN
AND A YEAH.
SIGNIFICANT GROUP OF EXCHANGE
STUDENTS FROM KAZAKHSTAN UKRAINE
SPAIN GERMANY ITALY AND FRANCE
ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT THEY ARE ALL PART OF
THE FUTURE LEADERS EXCHANGE
PROGRAM. AND I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE THEM TO YOU OF THIS
MORNING THEY ARE WITH US
IN THE GALLERY WELCOME
MEMBERS.
WE NOW MOVE TO THE SPECIAL
CEREMONY IN HONOR OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING HOLIDAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN A C.
R. ONE THIRTY NINE HOLDEN FOR
PURPOSES OF THIRD READING.
DOCTOR WEBER ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED ON THE ITEM.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
TO SEE
DOCTOR RIVER WANT OTHER CLERK
WILL READ ACR ONE THIRTY NINE.
SO WE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY NINE BY SOME WOMEN
BEHOLDEN ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO
REBEL DR MARTIN KING JUNIOR.
DOCTOR WERE YOU MAY OPEN ON THE
ON THE MOST OF THE AYE THANK
YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AS A VICE CHAIR OF THAT
CAUCUS.
TO PRESENT TO YOU ACR ONE THIRTY
NINE A RESOLUTION COMMEMORATING
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW DOCTOR KING
WAS BORN IN JANUARY FIFTEENTH OF
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE AND RAISED
IN THE SOUTH BY A FATHER WHO WAS
A BAPTIST MINISTER.
AND AT A VERY EARLY AGE HE
THOUGHT HE HAD THE CALLING ALSO
TO BECOME A MINISTER.
HOWEVER AS MOST THINGS DO LIFE
CHANGES YOU AND AS A RESULT TO
TAKE ON NEW CHALLENGES.
SO THAT IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
WHEN HE WAS APPROACH TO IT WHEN
HE WAS A MINISTER IN. AND AND
MONEY IN MONTGOMERY ALABAMA AT
EBENEZER BAPTIST CHURCH.
HE THEN BEGAN TWO OF DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE OF SEGREGATION WHEN IT
WAS BROUGHT TO HIM BY A GROUP OF
CITIZENS.
THAT ROSA PARKS HAD BEEN THROWN
OFF THE BUS.
AND THAT IT WAS NOW TIME FOR
PEOPLE TO THINK ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF SEGREGATION AND JIM CROW LAWS
THAT HAVE EXISTED IN THIS
COUNTRY. FOR CENTURY.
DOCTOR KING WAS ONLY TWENTY SIX
YEARS OLD WHEN HE DECIDED THAT
THIS WAS HIS WORK.
THAT HE WOULD TAKE UP THIS
ENORMOUS CHALLENGE.
IN THE END THE ERA OF TREMENDOUS
RACISM AND AND LYNCHINGS AND
BURNINGS AND INTIMIDATION.
DOCTOR KING DECIDED THAT THIS
WAS WORTH DEDICATING HIS LIFE
TO.
ENGAGED IN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
BOYCOTT.
WELL BEFORE OVER THIRTEEN MONTHS
IN MONTGOMERY ALABAMA.
THAT BASICALLY BROKE THE BACK OF
SEGREGATION BUSES.
AND INTEGRATED THE BUS SYSTEM IN
MONTGOMERY.
THAT PROPELLED HIM FORWARD AS A
AS A LEADER.
AND THIS NATION IN THE AREA OF
CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND THEY FOUGHT THEN INFORM THE
MONTGOMERY IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION.
AND BEGIN AT THAT POINT TO TALK
ABOUT ALL THE OTHER AREAS OF.
SEGREGATION AND DISCRIMINATION
IN THIS NATION.
MUCH OF YOU REMEMBER HIS GREAT
SPEECH IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
THAT I HAVE A DREAM.
WE'RE OVER A QUARTER MILLION
PEOPLE CAME TO WASHINGTON.
A PROTEST AGAINST SEGREGATION IN
THIS NATION.
IT RESULTED IN THE PASSAGE OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR. AND THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE.
IN THIRTEEN YEARS THIS YOUNG MAN
CHANGE THE DIRECTION AND THE
LIFE IN THE CULTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
AND THERE WAS A EFFORT INITIALLY
TO. OBVIOUSLY GIVE HIM A
CELEBRATION OF EARTH DAY.
OF THAT IT WAS RESISTED FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY CALIFORNIA BECAMETHE
FIRST STATE TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
CELEBRATION AND HOLIDAY AND ALL
OF ITS SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
FACILITIES.
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
COMMEMORATE THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF DOCTOR KING.
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT THAT
DOCTOR KING WOULD HAVE BEEN
EIGHTY NINE YEARS OLD ON MONDAY.
HE LIVED WELL HE'S BEEN DEAD
LONGER THEN HE LIVED. IN TERMS
OF DYING AT THE AGE OF THIRTY
NINE. A YOUNG MAN
WHO DEDICATED HIS WHOLE LIFE TO
WHAT WAS RIGHT WHAT WAS JUST.
AND I ASKED US TODAY TO
COMMEMORATE HIM IN THE PASSAGE
OF ACR ONE THIRTY NINE.
A ON THAT IN THIS HOUSE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
THERE ARE NO OTHER MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS
RESOLUTION DOCTOR WERE.
DOCTOR SHORT YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I MEMBERS I RISE SOUGHT TO.
JOING THE COMMEMORATION AND
CELEBRATION OF A DOCTOR.
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
BECAUSE.
.
JANUARY FIFTEEN.
OUR IS. A NATIONAL HOLIDAY
COMMEMORATING IS.
LEGACY AND ON CONTRIBUTION TO
THIS COUNTRY.
I ES.
.
MINORITY EMIGRANT WHO ARE.
HAS COME TO AMERICA AND.
REALIZED.
WHAT THE?
CONTRIBUTIONS.
ROLLED AWAY SO HE HAS.
PAY.
FOR PEOPLE OF OUR.
CALLER.
AND ARE MYSELF FOR I ACHIEVED.
SO CALLED DON'T AMERICAN DREAM.
WHEN I FIRST.
GOT ELECTED.
TO THE.
IRVINE SCHOOL BOARD.
MY.
STATEMENT
WHEN THAT DAY.
I USED.
NO NOT THE.
WORSE I COULD USE.
I THANK YOU COMMUNITY.
FOR ELECTING ME.
AND THE A HERE SO QUOTATION NOW
WHEN I USE.
USING YOUR JUDGMENT BIT ACTING
ME NOT BASED UPON THE OF COLOR
OFF TO SKI.
BUT THE.
WITH ALL CONTENT OF THE
CHARACTER AS YOU WOULD WE ALL
KNOW THAT A BUTTON WITH A KING.
JUNIO USED AND EXPRESSED.
AND A TODAY IS SO.
THAT THEY WE SHOULD THE
AUDITORIUM.
AND THEN ALSO I MAKE.
.
A YOU MORE OUT OF IT AND THE
JOKER AND I ENJOYED BECAUSE I
JANUARY FIFTEENTH. IS A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY TO COME COMMEMORATE.
MARTIN LUTHER JUNIOR.
TALKING JUNIOR SO.
.
BUT THEY. AND THE GAS WHAT'S
THERE HAPPENS TO BE MY BIRTHDAY
AND MY WIFE'S WHAT THE US WHILE
HER.
SO.
I'M BENEFITING KOREAN TO MY.
MAY KNOW JANUARY THIRTEENTH
ALIAS.
CELEBRATED AS OUT.
.
KOREAN AMERICAN DAY IN AMERICA
AND NEXT USED A.
AYE WOULD BE PRESENTING A NEW
RESOLUTION OF FOR YOUR ADOPTION
AS WE HAVE DONE NOT AND YOU ARE
THE. AND.
ALWAYS SOUGHT TO TWO DAYS OF
COURSE. WITH A COUPLE OF DAYS OF
A DIFFERENCE OF JANUARY
THIRTEENTH AND THE JANUARY
FIFTEENTH. SO WE EVERYWHERE IN
THE COMMUNITY WE CELEBRATE.
TALKED OF MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR DAY.
WITH THE.
A KOREAN AMERICAN DAY IN AMERICA
IN THE CONGRATULATIONS SAW A LOT
MY OR THE PEOPLE TODAY TO
ORGANIZE.
AND MOVE TOWARD A BETTER WORLD
AND CERTAINLY DOCTOR KING'S TIES
TO THE API COMMUNITY RUN DEEP.
A DOCTOR KING LINKS TO.
TO INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT ARE WELL DOCUMENTED.
FROM THE EARLY DAYS THE
MONTGOMERY BUS BOYCOTT KING
REFERRED TO INDIA'S MAHATMA
GANDHI AS THE GUIDING LIGHT OF
THE TECHNIQUE. OF NONVIOLENT
SOCIAL CHANGE.
A FEW YEARS LATER IN NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE DOCTOR KING AND HIS
WIFE CORETTA SCOTT KING TRAVEL
TO INDIA FOR A FIVE WEEK VISIT
FOR THE SPECIFIC PURPOSE. OF DR
KING LEARNING MORE ABOUT NON
VIOLENT NON COOPERATION AND
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE.
UPON ARRIVAL HE'S YOU KNOW HE'S
NOT HE'S QUOTED AS SAYING TO
OTHER COUNTRIES I MAKE GOES THE
TOURISTS BUT INDIA I COME AS A
PILGRIM.
IN ENDING HIS TRIP A DOCTOR
DOCTOR KING. SAID SINCE BEING IN
INDIA I AM MORE CONVINCED THAN
EVER BEFORE THAT THE METHOD OF
NONVIOLENT RESISTANCE IS THE
MOST POTENT WEAPON AVAILABLE TO
OPPRESSED PEOPLE. IN THEIR
STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE AND HUMAN
DIGNITY.
WE HAVE LEADERS LIKE DOUGHERTY
THINK DOCTOR KING TO THANK FOR
AS HE WAS AMONG THOSE WHO
IGNITED A FIRE. THAT INSPIRES
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS SUCH AS
YOU RECALL CHIOMA IN HER FIGHT
FOR TRUTH AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AS WELL AS GRACED THE BOX WHO
FAMOUSLY HELPED ORGANIZE DR
KING'S WALK TO FREEDOM IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE IN DETROIT.
SPEECH THAT SPOKE OF UNITY
RESPECT AND HOPE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY BY THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE MEMBER AND FORMER
INTERNEE TODD ANDO. JOIN DR KING
IN HIS MARGIN SOLOMON SUPPORTING
IN THE SUPPORT OF VOTING RIGHTS
FIFTY YEARS LATER IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN JCL MEMBERS
WERE INSPIRED TO VISIT SELMA
ONCE AGAIN IN CAN RIP
COMMEMORATION OF DR KING'S
CONTRIBUTIONS.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS
AND OF COURSE MANY OF US MY
FAMILY INCLUDED CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY SUBSEQUENT IMMIGRATION
NATURALIZATION ACT NINETEEN
SIXTY BY WHICH WAS A CRITICAL
PIECE. OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT TO ALLOW.
BOOK POKES HIM ALL OVER THE
WORLD TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY TO
SEEK THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AND IN DOCTOR KING'S FINALS
FINAL WEEKS AND PUSHING THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN AND ECONOMIC
BILL OF RIGHTS. OUT OF WHICH.
THE MEMPHIS SANITATION STRIKE
HE INDICATED WAS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF.
NOW WE KNOW THAT HIS STRUGGLE
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY WENT
BEYOND RACIAL EQUALITY BUT IT
WAS A FIGHT FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE
FOR ALL PEOPLE IN THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN. WAS A MULTI
RACIAL MULTI ETHNIC UP OF.
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING TOGETHER
STRUGGLING PEOPLE FROM AROUND
THE NATION TO FIGHT FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE AND I. IMPLORE ALL OF US
TO REMEMBER THAT AS WE SEEK TO
DO THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS THAT
BEYOND JUST CELEBRATING DOCTOR
KING FOR WHAT HE WAS REMEMBER
WHO E. STILL IS. AND ABOUT HIS
MESSAGE STILL RESONATES TO THIS
DAY FOR THOSE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING ABOUT OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION.
IN THESE TIMES WHERE HOPE IS SO
ESSENTIAL TO PROGRESS WE ARE
TRULY GRATEFUL BEYOND MEASURE TO
DOCTOR KING FOR HIS LIFETIME
COMMITMENT. AND DEDICATION TO
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN VOTING AYE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE IN HONOR OF DR
KING'S LIFE AND WORK.
REALLY RECOGNIZE FROM YOUR DESK.
SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
CELEBRATE THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
TODAY'S COMMEMORATION. COMES AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR TO
STRAIGHTEN OUR RESOLVE.
TO WORK FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
ALL OF THOSE IN WHICH WE SERVE.
DOCTOR KING WORKED TIRELESSLY.
TO BRING CIVIL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE TO THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
A PRICE OF.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
HE WORKED ACROSS ALL COMMUNITIES
HE REACHED OUT TO LEADERS IN THE
CHICANO LATINO MOVEMENT. LIKE
CORKY GONZALEZ AND CESAR CHAVEZ.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX HERO TO
CESAR CHAVEZ IN A TELEGRAM AND
SAID. AS BROTHERS IN THE FIGHT
FOR EQUALITY I EXTEND THE HAND
THE FELLOWSHIP IN GOOD WILL AND
WISH CONTINUED SUCCESS TO YOU
AND YOUR MEMBERS. THE FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY MUST BE FOUGHT ON MANY
FRONTS.
IN THE URBAN SLUMS AND THE SWEAT
SHOPS OF THE FACTORIES AND
FIELDS ARE SEPARATE STRUGGLES
ARE REALLY WHAT. A STRUGGLE FOR
FREEDOM FOR DIGNITY AND FOR
HUMANITY.
IN THIS MOMENT IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
AS HATEFUL RHETORIC SPEWS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I HOPE THAT EVERY CHILD WOMAN
AND MAN CAN LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND SAY I AM SOMEBODY.
I AM SOMEBODY.
MEMBERS.
LET US REALIZE.
THE DREAM OF MARTIN LUTHER KING.
A COUNTRY OF EQUITY OPPORTUNITY
AND JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE.
NOT JUST A FEW.
AS I LOOK AROUND THIS CHAMBER.
WE HAVEN'T MANY WAYS REACH THE
MOUNTAIN TOP.
AND OF CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST NOW DELIVER.
ON THAT PROMISE LAND.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR THURMAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS.
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE THIRTY NINE
AND I THINK THE OFFER FROM SAN
DIEGO. FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
BRINGING IT FOR.
IS IMPORTANT TODAY THAT WE
REFLECT ON AN AMERICAN HERO WHO
WAS COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
CIVIL RIGHTS.
IN ACHIEVING EQUALITY.
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR OUR NATION
HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO A RISE IN
DEPRESSIVE RHETORIC.
YOU KNOW PHOBIA INTOLERANCE
IN DISCRIMINATION IN OUR
NATION'S MEDIA AND THIS
COUNTRY'S HIGHEST OFFICE.
WE WOULD BE WISE
TO CONSIDER THE TEACHINGS OF
RABBI HILLEL.
ONE OF JUDAISM'S MOST IMPORTANT
THINKERS.
HE ASKED HIS STUDENTS TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE FOLLOWING THREE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
IF I AM NOT FOR MYSELF.
WHO WILL BE FOR ME?
IF I AM ONLY FOR MYSELF.
WHAT AM I?
IF NOT NOW.
WHEN.
DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
RABBI ABRAHAM JOSHUA HESCHEL
MARCHED WITH DOCTOR KING FIFTY
FOUR MILES FROM SELMA.
TO MONTGOMERY SAYING THAT OUR
CALLS FOR MORAL GRANDEUR IN
SPIRITUAL AUDACITY.
SIMILARLY OUR PRESENT MOMENT
REQUIRES MORAL GRANDEUR AND
SPIRITUAL AUDACITY.
IF WE ARE FOR OURSELVES
THEN WHO ARE WE.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE MUST COME
TOGETHER AND DEFEND THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS OF ALL
PEOPLE.
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IN THE
JEWISH CAUCUS IS PROUD TO STAND
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN THE MANY OTHER
CAUCUSES THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM
TODAY. ON THIS DAY AS WE HONOR
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
AS I. AS I THINK ABOUT THIS
MOMENT. IN.
HOW PROUD I AM TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE?
IN.
THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
THE LATINO CAUCUS
I THINK IT IS ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE WORK OF SOMEONE LIKE DOCTOR
KING.
THAT A PERSON LIKE MYSELF.
SERVE ON THIS FLOOR.
A PERSON WHO'S.
FAMILIES EMIGRATED FROM PLACES
LIKE PANAMA.
IN COLOMBIA IN JAMAICA.
WHOSE ANCESTORS WERE BROUGHT
HERE AS SLAVES
THE PLACES
LIKE MISSISSIPPI.
TO A MAN WHO PRACTICES JUDAISM.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF
DOCTOR KING. THAT I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN THIS
CHAMBER.
IF I HAD A MESSAGE TODAY I WOULD
I WOULD PARK IN THE WORDS OF
DOCTOR KING.
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT THE FIERCE
URGENCY OF NOW.
HIS LEGACY LEAVES US WITH SO
MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT HAVE MADE OUR COUNTRY
BETTER. IN GREATER. HIS MESSAGE
ABOUT THE ONENESS OF HUMANITY IS
A SPECIAL ONE AND HAS BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT FOR SO MANY OF US.
BUT YET WE CONTINUE IN THIS
PRESENT DAY.
TO SEE SO MANY REMNANTS OF
HATRED.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
IN POLITICS.
YOU NEED ONLY TURN ON YOUR
TELEVISION.
TO HEAR COMMENTS BEING MADE.
BASED ON RACE AND ETHNICITY.
THAT WOULD DRIVE US APART.
THAT HAVE IMPACTED OUR FAMILIES
WHO EMIGRATE FROM ALL KINDS OF
PLACES LIKE OUR NEIGHBORS IN
MEXICO. OR ELSE SALVADOR.
OR HAITI.
THAT WE STILL SEE EVIDENCE OF
THE KU KLUX KLAN. IN THE NEO
NAZIS AS RECENT AS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
LETS US KNOW THAT NOW MORE THAN
EVER. ALL OF US MUST ACT IN THE
WAY THAT KING DIRECTED. AND THAT
WE MUST ACT WITH THE FIERCE
URGENCY OF NOW THAT WE MUST LOCK
ARMS TOGETHER. AND STAND AGAINST
HATE AND PROMOTE.
THE ONE THIS OF HUMANITY.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ON ACR ONE THIRTY NINE.
THURMAN DOCTOR REGULARLY
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW I HAVE TO BE A LITTLE
CAREFUL WHEN I START SPEAKING
ABOUT DOCTOR KING BECAUSE
THERE'S A FEW PEOPLE WHO REALLY.
GET TO ME.
WHO SPEAK TO ME IN A WAY THAT
FIRES US UP AND I BELIEVE IT'S
BECAUSE DOCTOR KING WAS A BIT OF
A SOCIAL ARSONIST?
HE ACTUALLY BELIEVED THAT YOU
HAD TO AGITATE AND CREATE SOME.
ISSUES
TO GET CHANGE.
MANY OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW BUT
OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO HE CAME TO
FRESNO ONE TIME JUST ONE TIME.
AND THE CAME BACK THEN BECAUSE
HE WAS ARGUING FOR HOW WE NEEDED
TO ADVANCE THE HOUSING ISSUES
WITHIN OUR CITY.
IT WAS JUST YESTERDAY.
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO FINALLY GET
A RENTAL HOUSING INSPECTION
POLICY THAT WILL HAVE MET WHAT
DOCTOR KING WAS STILL TRYING TO
DO IT TOOK FIFTY YEARS.
PROBLEMS THAT WERE HAPPENING IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT HE SAW BACK
THEN ARE STILL PREVALENT NOW IT
TAKES SOMEONE LIKE. DOCTOR KING
TO STAND UP AND FIGHT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I'M PROUD TODAY
SAY AND STAND FOR ACR ONE THIRTY
NINE.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITY THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
WERE SOCIAL ARSONISTS WHO FOUGHT
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
BELIEVE DOCTOR KING NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS HARD WORK.
I WANT TO SAY ONE LAST THING IF
I CAN'T.
WHAT HE FOUGHT FOR THAT
INEQUALITY WITH SEPARATE BUT
UNEQUAL THAT STILL OCCURS TODAY?
WE STILL HAVE PARTS OF OUR
SOCIETY WHICH ARE MARGINALIZED
WHICH ARE WITHIN. SHADOWS.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO
HAVE A LARGER DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW WE DON'T LISTEN TO THE HATE
RHETORIC.
BUT LISTEN TO HIS LOVE AND
OPTIMISM THAT'S A MESSAGE THAT
WE AS A COMMUNITY NEED TO BE
LISTENING TO RIGHT NOW.
SO I THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD HE HAS
IMPACTED SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU.
WHAT HE DID FOR MY COMMUNITY?
AND WHERE HE CAME AND WHAT IT
MEANT TO ME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
I CAN DOCTOR AND BELOW ZERO ANY
FURTHER QUESTION A DEBATE ON THE
MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING ON DOCTOR
WERE YOU MAY CLOSE.
YES MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AS WE. DISCUSS THE
CELEBRATION OF DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING AND ACR ONE THIRTY NINE.
YEAH I WAS TRYING TO THINK OF
WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY TODAY TO.
CLOSE UP THE CELEBRATION.
THIS IS PROBABLY MY SIXTH TIME
SPEAKING ON THIS FLOOR
CONCERNING MARTIN LUTHER KING.
AND WHAT I THINK THE CAME TO ME
IS A REALIZATION THAT COME THIS
A PROBLEM THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FIFTY YEARS. SINCE DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING LIT THAT HE WAS
ASSASSINATED ON APRIL FOURTH.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHEN I WAS
A STUDENT AT UCLA.
AND THEN I REALIZE THAT PROBABLY
IN THIS HOUSE MOST OF YOU NEVER
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO REALLY SEE A LIVE
PRESENTATION.
AB DOCTOR KING.
MOST OF YOU NOT FIFTY YEARS OLD.
SO YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF HIM IS IS
IS KNOWLEDGE THAT HAS BEEN
TRANSFERRED DOWN FROM THOSE WHO
WOULD BEER OR BOOKS OR ARTICLES
IN NEWSPAPERS.
BUT I'M NOT SURE IF YOU REALLY
GRASS HOW DIFFICULT THE
CHALLENGE WAS.
IN HIS LIFETIME.
AS MOST OF YOU NO I WAS RAISED
IN I WAS BORN IN HOPE ARKANSAS
MY FAMILY IS STILL THERE MANY OF
THEM.
BUT WE'VE TRAVELLED THEY'RE
OFTEN SO I HAD THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE KINDS OF.
THINGS THAT WE THINK ARE
WONDERFUL AMENITIES IN TERMS OF
RACE RELATIONS IN COMPARISON TO
THE SOUTH.
BUT I TRAVEL TO THE SOUTH QUITE
OFTEN.
AND I SAW THE SIGNS OF WHITE IN
COLOR.
I UNDERSTOOD THE INCONVENIENCE
OF TRYING TO FIND A RESTROOM TO
USE AT A SERVICE STATION.
I KNEW WHAT IT WAS LIKE WITH TO
DRIVE FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND
NOT BE ABLE TO STOP BECAUSE IT
WAS NO PLACE YOU COULD STOP TO
STAY. AND IF YOU STOPPED YOU
WERE AFRAID OF WHAT YOU MIGHT
SEE ONCE YOU LEFT CROSS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THERE IS ONLY
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU WOULD SEE WHEN
TO BREAK REACHED TEXAS. AND
BEYOND.
AND SO I UNDERSTAND SO MANY OF
US DON'T DON'T WE HAVE A SENSE
ABOUT IT.
BUT MAYBE NOT A SENSE OF HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS AND HOW DEEP IT
WAS IN THE SOCIETY THE HATRED
THAT WAS THERE. BED BUILDING
BUILT UP OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS
OF HATRED.
AND HOW THAT PERMEATED EVERY
ELEMENT OF A PERSON'S LIFE.
FINDING WHERE THEY WENT HOW THEY
LIVE WHERE THEY EIGHT WHERE THEY
STAYED.
HOW FAR THEY COULD GO AND NOT
GOAL A SOCIETY IN THE COMMUNITY?
AND THAT BECAME REALLY A
DIFFICULT THING TO TRANSFER
SOMETIMES TO YOUNG PEOPLE.
THE FACT THAT THIS BATTLE WERE
IN IS A BATTLE IS A LIFE BATTLE.
IT YOU CAN'T REALLY RELAX ON YOU
CAN'T GIVE UP ON BECAUSE IF TO
GO IT'S IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
THEM CLIMBING THAT MOUNTAIN OF
DISCRIMINATION. TRYING TO GET TO
SOME FREEDOM IN SOME JUSTICE AT
THE TOP.
KNOWING THAT EVERY STEP WAS
DIFFICULT AND EVERY STEP MIGHT
MEAN YOUR LIFE.
AND BUT IT IS REAL EASY TO ROLL
DOWN THE HILL.
WITHOUT THINKING.
YOU KNOW THE RACISM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WAS BUILT UP OVER DECADES.
WHEN THE FIRST SLAVES WERE
BROUGHT HERE IN THE SIXTEEN
HUNDREDS.
THEY WOULD NOT NO ONE THOUGHT
THAT THERE WOULD BE THIS.
ENORMOUS SYSTEM OF
DISCRIMINATION.
AND HE WON AND LITTLE BY LITTLE
LAW BY LAW ATTITUDE BY ATTITUDE.
WE END UP WITH THE WORST SLAVE
SYSTEM IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
ONE THAT WAS JUST NOT ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL BEING SINCE LATE BUT
GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS AND
GENERATIONS OF PEOPLE WHO OWNED
BY OTHERS WITH THE RIGHT TO
ABUSE OF MACHINES IN ANY
CAPACITY THAT THEY THOUGHT.
AND SO THAT HAPPENED LITTLE BY
LITTLE.
AND SO WHEN EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION COMES IN IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE. AND THE
WAR ENDS IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF FREEDOM FOR
ABOUT.
FIFTEEN YEARS.
DOING RECONSTRUCTION.
AND THEN LITTLE BY LITTLE.
LAW BY LAW.
ATTITUDE BUT ADDED TO THAT BEGAN
TO CHANGE TO WE ENDED UP WITH
THE NEW SYSTEM CALLED JIM CROW.
AND I SAY THIS BECAUSE SOMETIMES
WE THINK PEOPLE RIDE INTO THESE
ISSUES YOU KNOW FULL FULL
FLEDGED WITH THE PROGRAM IN A
PROCESS THAT THEY CAN PUT OUT
THE.
WITHOUT REALIZING THAT STEP BY
STEP PIECE BY PIECE.
YOU BILL THIS IS THE SYSTEM OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HATRED.
AND SO I I RECOGNIZE THAT MANY
OF YOU WERE NOT A PART OF THAT
DIDN'T DON'T YOU GET IT BUT YOU
DON'T YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT
EMPATHIZING WITH BECAUSE IT'S
NOT REALLY SOMETHING TO SOLVE
THE TO LIVE WITH THAT YOU WORK
WITH.
AND YOU KNOW HOW PROUD WE WERE
WOULDN'T WHEN WE SAW DOCTOR KING
AT A RALLY ARE MARKED.
AND HOW COURAGEOUS HE WAS WHEN
HE CAME TO SAN DIEGO AND EVEN
THE MINISTERS AND SAID IT WOULD
NOT LET HIM SPEAK AT THE
CHURCHES.
BECAUSE THEY WERE AFRAID OF
WHITE BACKLASH.
AND SO AS A RESULT HE TALKED HE
SPOKE AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY IN THE JAIL BECAUSE
THEY WOULD NOT LET HIM SPEAK AT
THE LARGEST BLACK BAPTIST CHURCH
IN SAN DIEGO BECAUSE THEY WERE
AFRAID OF THIS RADICAL. WHO
MIGHT CAUSE TROUBLE WHO MAY MAKE
PROBLEMS A DIFFICULTY FOR THEM?
AND SO WHEN WHEN I BEGAN TO ASK
MYSELF AS WE LOOK AT THIS.
AND SAY YOU KNOW THERE'S A
GENERATION. THAT WILL DON'T YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE
YOU HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE OF.
WHICH MAKES THIS DAY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS CELEBRATION
WITHOUT THIS DAY YOU COULD
AFFORD TO NOT EVEN THINK ABOUT
MARTIN LUTHER KING AND ALL THE
STRUGGLES THAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AS WE'VE FACE THIS NEW
CHALLENGE WE ARE NOW FACED WITH
THE CHALLENGE THAT IS ENORMOUS
IN THIS NATION.
CHALLENGE TO TO BASICALLY BE
AMERICANS.
TO HOLD FAST TO THE VALUES AND
THE PRINCIPLES THAT WE BELIEVE
IN. THAT ARE UNDER ATTACK EVERY
DAY AS WE GET THE HATE MESSAGE
THAT SPEWS OUT AGAINST DIFFERENT
IMMIGRANTS IN DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS.
AND WHILE WE MIGHT BE ALL THAT
SOUTH NOT SO BAD BUT THE REALITY
YEARS. IT IS BAD.
IT GETS TO THE HEART OF WHAT
THIS NATION FOUGHT FOR AND WHAT
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
AND IT IS INDIVIDUALS LIKE US.
WHO DON'T MAKE STATEMENTS
WHO DON'T ROCK THE BOAT WHO
DON'T MOVE THE WATERS
QUIETLY SAY I DON'T AGREE WITH
YOU DON'T STAND UP AND SHOUT?
YOU DON'T STAND IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND SAY STOP IT.
WE CANNOT HAVE THAT THAT IS NOT
WHO WE ARE.
AND SO PAYING OFTEN SAID IT'S
NOT THE WORDS OF MY ENEMIES THAT
BOTHER ME IT'S THE SILENCE OF MY
FRIENDS.
IT'S AFFECTED WE DON'T SPEAK UP.
WE DON'T SPEAK OUT WE DON'T
CONDEMN THOSE THINGS WHEN I SEE
WHAT'S ON TELEVISION NOW WHEN I
SEE CHARLOTTE VIOLA AND AND ALL
THE RIGHTS AND THEN PLOP RIGHT
NASH'S MOVE AND ALL THAT. I'M
WONDERING WHERE MY FRIENDS.
WELL MY COLLEAGUES WHO WANT TO
BE STANDING UP AND SHOUTING IN
STREAMING SCREAMING IN THE THE
TO THE TOP OF THE VOICE. BECAUSE
WE HAVE COME TOO FAR.
WHAT TOO LONG AND TOO HARD TO BE
PULLED BACK INTO THIS DARK THIS
OF HATE?
UGLINESS IN THIS NATION.
IF SO AS WE LOOK AT THE DOCTOR
KING DAY I AM HOPEFUL THAT
PEOPLE WILL BEGIN TO SEE
SOMETHING IN THEMSELVES.
THE CAUSES THEM TO RISE UP.
AND THE SAY NOT ON MY WATCH.
NOT WHILE I'M HERE.
NOT IN MY COMMUNITY NOT IN MY
NATION.
AND THAT BOTHERS ME MORE THAN
ANYTHING BECAUSE OFTENTIMES YOU
SEE THE THINGS THAT OCCUR.
BUT YOU ASKED THE QUESTION WHERE
ARE THE FOLKS WHO ONE FIGHT
AGAINST IT.
WHO DON'T BELIEVE IN IT BUT
WON'T OPEN THEIR MOUTHS?
AND THE BEAUTY OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING CELEBRATION DAY IS
THAT IT ONCE AGAIN REMINDS US.
THAT ONE PERSON.
STANDING FULL RIGHT.
CAN TRULY CHANGE THE WORLD.
ONE PERSON WITH A DETERMINATION
TO MOTIVATE OTHERS TO JOIN THEM
CAN CHANGE THE WORLD.
AND HE OFTEN SAID IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING YOU'RE WILLING TO
DIE FOR YOU REALLY HAVE NOTHING
TO LIVE FOR.
IF THESE PRINCIPLES THAT ARE
TRULY AMERICAN PRINCIPLE.
HOW WE TREAT EACH OTHER?
HOW RESPECT THE VALUES THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS NATION HOW
WE PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND THE
LEGACY WE PASS ON TO THEM?
IS SO EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND SO I CHALLENGE TODAY TO BE
THAT AMERICA AS AS THE BLOCK
PORT ONCE SAID THE NUMBER WAS
WOULD GET MUST BE.
THE THE THE NATION THAT HAS BEEN
THAT SAYS IT EMBRACES EVERYONE
BUT HAS YET TO DO IT.
BUT NATION THAT IS SUPPOSE TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE AND HAS NOT.
I CHALLENGE JUST TO BE THAT
NATION THAT WOULD THAT KING
TALKED ABOUT.
THE MOUNTAIN TOP EXPERIENCE THAT
HE COULD STAND AND SEE THE
PROMISED LAND.
BUT MANY OF US I HAVE BEGUN TO
WALK BACK DOWN THAT MOUNTAIN WHY
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE IT'S A
FAMILIAR TRAIL AND IS
CONVENIENT.
AND IT IS HARD WORK TO BE FREE.
IT'S HARD WORK EVEN HARDER WORK
TO STAY FREE.
AND I CHALLENGE YOU TODAY TO
REMEMBER ALWAYS.
THAT HATRED.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
WANT.
BUT JUSTICE EQUALITY OPPORTUNITY
IS A RARE FLOWER.
THAT REQUIRES CONSTANT TREATMENT
AND NURTURING AND CARE.
BUT HATRED IS WEAK.
AND IT GROWS BEST IN NEGLECT.
AND I ASKED TO NO LONGER
NEGLECT.
THE THINGS THAT ARE SO HORRIBLE.
THAT WE SPEAK OUT.
SPEAK UP.
AND WE BECOME THE PEOPLE THAT WE
BELIEVE WE ARE.
NOT JUST FOR US
BUT FOR GENERATIONS AND
GENERATIONS TO COME.
MISTER SPEAKER I ASK THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OFTEN OPEN FOR
COAL AUTHORS ON ACR ONE THIRTY
NINE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
ALL DEBATE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED WE WERE
MOVED TO VOTE ON THE MEASURE.
ARE THE FIRST.
FIRST ROLL CALL WILL BE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RULES.
AND
.
THE RESISTANCE FOR COOPERS
WE HAVE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
YOU LIKE TO THANK GOD DOCTOR
WEBER.
FOR HER PRESENTATION.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS.
APRIL FOURTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
THE DEATH BY ASSASSINATION.
WELL DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR.
WELL THE WORLD'S MOST NOTABLE.
THE MOST INSPIRATIONAL LEADERS.
LAST YEAR OF HIS LIFE. WAS A
TUMULTUOUS ONE FOR DR KING.
HE WORKED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
WAR IN VIETNAM.
ORGANIZE THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN AND WAS JAILED IN
BIRMINGHAM.
ALTHOUGH HE IS NO LONGER HERE IN
THE PHYSICAL SENSE.
HIS LEGACY REMAINS.
AS PART OF OUR OBSERVANCE OF THE
NATIONAL AND STATE HOLIDAY TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
THE MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
RECORDED. THEIR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT DOCTOR KING AND HIS LEGACY
MEANS TO THEIR.
ROOM NOW VIEW THIS VIDEO WITH
THE REFLECTIONS OF THE MEMBERS.
PLEASE THEM THE LIGHTS.
BEGIN THE VIDEO.
MME INGRAINED AT MEMORY OF
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING. WAS.
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE EVER WITNESSED MY FATHER
CRYING. IT A TREMENDOUS IMPACT.
ON MY.
I HEAR AFTER HIS DEATH
FOR EACH BLOCK FAMILY.
ON OUR STREET AND WE REMEMBER I
REMEMBER.
THOSE WHO WELCOMED US BUT THOSE
WHO LOOKED AT US WITH GREAT
DISDAIN I REMEMBER THE MARGIN
WASHINGTON I REMEMBER THE
THRONGS OF PEOPLE AND ALL THE
EX.
WHAT?
MARGARET KING MEANT.
ALSO REMEMBER HIS DEATH
ALL WHAT I WAS A COLLEGE AND A
HOWL IMPACT THAT THAT WASN'T MY
LIFE IN TERMS OF. FEELING SUCH A
DEEP HURT BUT SOMEONE HAD.
TAKEN THE LIFE OF DOT
KING AND AT THE SAME TIME
ALL OF US WERE COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE DREAM WOULD
NOT DIE WITHOUT
KING THAT WE HAD A COMMITMENT.
MAKE SURE THAT DREAM CONTINUE TO
LIVE AT.
STORIES THAT.
MY FATHER SHARED ABOUT HIS
GRANDPARENTS.
RACIAL INJUSTICE.
INEQUALITY
NOW A HUNDRED YEARS AGO BUT
THOSE SAME ISSUES OUR WITH US
TODAY MY PARENTS WILL RECEIVE
THEIR IN THE AIRFORCE MY FATHER
WAS. THE STATION IN FRANCE I WAS
BORN
THE TOUGH BUT THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT WHAT DOCTOR KING HELPED
CONTRIBUTE TO. HOW CAME ABOUT IT
WOULD HAPPEN THEY WERE SO HAPPY?
BECAUSE GROWING UP IN THE SOUTH
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. AND HOW IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE DIED IN
FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND HOW SHE ALWAYS VOTE AND HOW
IMPORTANT WAS
WHEN I VISITED THE NATIONAL
MONUMENT I WAS BROUGHT BACK TO A
SPEECH I REMEMBER READING OF
DOCTOR CHANGES IT. WAS ENTITLED
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE WITH
HIS LAST SPEECH HE DELIVERED TO
THE SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE BEFORE HIS
ASSASSINATION. IN THE SPEECH HE
DRAWS THE CORRELATION BETWEEN
POWER AND LOVE.
AND WHAT HE SAYS IS WHAT'S
NEEDED IS THE REALIZATION THAT
POWER WITHOUT LOVE THIS RECKLESS
AND ABUSIVE AND LOVE WITHOUT
POWER IS SENTIMENTAL IN AN
ANEMIC. POWER AT ITS BEST DR
KING SAYS IS LOVE IMPLEMENTING
THE DEMANDS OF JUSTICE AND
JUSTICE AT ITS BEST ITS POWER
CORRECTING EVERYTHING THAT
STANDS AGAINST LOW.
I'M.
.
WHAT I REMEMBER MOST OF ALL
GROWING UP AND WHAT'S?
IS THAT WE WALK THROUGH THE
DOOR.
OUR FAMILY HOME.
BEFORE YOU SAW ANYTHING ELSE
THE TV THE FURNITURE YOU SAW
THREE PICTURES.
AND IT WAS SIGNIFICANT NOW IN MY
HOME BUT WAS REPRESENTED IN
OTHER PEOPLE'S HOMES
AND THAT WAS A PICKED OF DOCTOR
MARTHA KING.
JOHN F. KENNEDY.
AND JESUS.
AND WHEN WE CAME HOME.
THOSE ARE THREE PICTURES WE SAW.
WHEN WE LEFT THE HOME.
THOSE ARE THREE FIXES WERE SAW
IT AS A YOUNG MAN I WATCHED MANY
SPEECHES BY DOCTOR KING AND
PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANTLY THE I
AM TRIMS
EACH I THINK I'VE SEEN IT ON.
I COULD RECITE IT NOW I CAN GIVE
IT NOW AND I THINK IT HAS STAYED
WITH ME THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
AND THROUGHOUT MY LIFE AND I CAN
THINK OF NO.
PUBLIC
FIGURE WHO'S HAD MORE IMPACT ON
ME. ENDING UP.
SERVICE.
MILEPOST ONE REALLY ROCK NINE
TONIGHT THIS INTEGRATED CENTRAL
HIGH SCHOOL MAKE.
SEVEN.
FOLLOWS ALWAYS TOLD ABOUT THEIR
STRUGGLES
AND THE STRUGGLES OF OUR PEOPLE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT.
MY FAMILY TOLD US ABOUT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND FROM THAT DAY.
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN IN THAT
SCHOOL PART IN CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. AND I'VE BEEN.
SOMEONE WHO.
HAS TO BE
PART OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT BECAUSE THAT IS
COMPARTMENTALIZED HISSY BUT IS
WHAT I HAVE TO GIVE THAT. WAS
BECAUSE THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
LIE MEMORY OF DOCTOR KING IS
MORE ABOUT MY MOTHER. A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE HE DIED.
HE SPOKE ABOUT HIS DESIRE FOR
HER TO BE IN CONGRESS.
AND WHAT GREAT POSSIBILITY SHE
BROUGHT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO ON MY DESK I KEEP
THAT PICTURE. OF MY MOTHER AND
DOCTOR KING AND IT REMINDS ME
EVERY DAY OF HOW. LUCKY I AM TO
GET TO WALK ON THE GREEN CARPET.
HOW IMPORTANT MY BEING THERE IS
NOT JUST TO MY COMMUNITY?
BUT TO MY DAUGHTER WHO HOPEFULLY
NOT UNLIKE MY MOM WAS AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I AM NOW ON THE
CARPET AND AND.
EVEN IN LIGHT OF THAT CLAIM IT
TODAY WHAT IS POSSIBLE FOR MY
CHILD'S DOCTOR KING CAME TO
PASADENA FRIENDSHIP BAPTIST
CHURCH.
THAT I REMEMBER AS A CHILD. THE
LINE STRETCHING OUT THE CHURCH
AND AROUND THE CORNER MY MOM.
HELD MY HAND OF OUR BROTHERS AND
SEE.
MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO MY ON THIS
YEAR'S GOING TO MAKE HER WAY
THROUGH THE CROWD SHAKE HIS HAND
SHE MADE HER WAY THROUGH.
AND SHE REACHED UP AND HE LOOKED
DOWN. AND HE REACHED OUT AND HE
SHOOK HER HAND. AND YOU FELT THE
POWER OF HIS PRESENCE.
BUT ALSO THE TENACITY OF MY MOM.
TO MAKE HER WAY TO THIS PERSON
WHO SHE WAS INSPIRED BY AS WELL.
RIGHT NOW WITH INITIAL DR KING
NEVER WIN THAT CAME BEFORE US
WHETHER THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
OR THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT FOLK THE
REMARKS.
A FIGHT FEELS RIGHT.
IN THIS SCENE CIVIL RIGHT TO
VOTE RIGHT TO BE A MAN THE RIGHT
TO RIDE A BUS THROUGH THE
COUNTER EACH FOOD THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT WATCHING DOCTOR KING.
AND THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT REALLY
INSPIRED ME AS A YOUNG PERSON TO
THINK ABOUT. WHAT COULD I DO TO
HELP OTHERS AND I DIDN'T KNOW?
WHAT THAT JOURNEY WOULD BE? BUT
I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO HELP
OTHERS AND I AS AN ADULT YOU
KNOW I'VE WORKED ENTIRELY. IN
THE NONPROFIT WORLDS. WORKING
FOR AMERICORPS AND PUBLIC
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS AND. WE
OFTEN VOLUNTEERED ON KING DAY
I'VE ALWAYS.
.
MARVELED AT HIS ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE PEOPLE. WITH IDEAS AND
WITH. OF THE POWER OF OF A GOOD
THOUGHT IN THE WAY TO. TO MOVE
FROM MATT HUMANITY TO ANOTHER
LEVEL HIS LEGACY IS RICH AND
IT'S INCLUSIVE.
AND IT'S A LEGACY THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO LIVE ON IF I CAN
JUST HELP SOMEBODY.
ALONG THE WAY.
THEN MY LIVING HERE. WOULD NOT
BE AND THAT I THINK ABOUT SO
MANY PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
INTERCEDED CALIFORNIA THAT. YOU
KNOW BUT FOR DR KING AND THAT
AND PEOPLE IN HIS GENERATION.
WE WOULD HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AND AND GRANTED
THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO LOOK WE
SEE THAT. RACIAL INEQUALITY AND
INJUSTICE.
EVERY DAY HERE IN OUR GREAT
STATE. CLAIM INTO.
THE PRISON SYSTEM TO OUR SCHOOLS
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO WE
REALLY.
EVERITT OUT BECAUSE IT'S A LOT
OF GOOD PEOPLE IN SILENT ALL
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN AMERICA
RIGHT NOW AS IT RELATES TO RACE
AS IT RELATES TO GENDER. AS IT
RELATES TO RELIGION AND I WOULD
NEVER EVER.
EVER.
.
SPAULDING THE LEGACY OF DOCTOR
KING BY NOT STANDING UP FOR.
FIRST RIGHTS AND ENSURE THAT WE
STAND FOR OTHER PEOPLE I THINK
OF HOW HARD IT WAS THE DOCTOR
CAME IN MEMBERS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH MY JOURNEY MAYBE HEART
THE THINGS I LOOK AT A
DIFFICULT.
BUT THE REALITY IS IT'S MUCH
EASIER THAN DR KING THAT
MOTIVATES ME TO REALIZE THAT I'M
JUST REALLY DOING SOMETHING
SMALL. IN COMPARISON TO WHAT HE
DID AND I SHOULD HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO THAT. I AM ALSO
CONSTANTLY REMINDED.
THAT.
THE JUNE.
IT WAS NOT JUST FOR ME.
IT WAS NOT JUST FOR AYE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LITTLE GIRL.
IT IS FOR ALL OF US AND THAT WE
ARE ALL BETTER WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER AND NOT I BELIEVE WAS
TRULY THE TRADE OF DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
HERE.
THERE IS A TESTIMONIAL THAT AT
ONE POINT I DID HAVE HERE.
IN THE INTERVENING YEARS SINCE
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
THE QUEST FOR JUSTICE FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND ALL
AMERICANS HAS CONTINUED.
THE CBC ESTABLISHED THE UNSUNG
HERO AWARD IN HONOR OF DR KING.
TO RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO EMBODY
THE FOR HIS PHILOSOPHY AND
IDEAS.
WE CONTINUE THIS TRADITION WITH
THE STELLAR GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO WE HONOR HERE TODAY.
I'M APPOINTING AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE TO BRING OUR HONOREES
ONTO THE FLOOR FOR A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION.
MEMBERSHIP RETIRED TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL YOUR
NAME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BURKE.
COOPER.
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
THURMOND.
WEBER.
AND OUR SPECIAL GUESTS
SENATOR HOLLINGS RITUAL.
I ASK MAJORITY LEADER. IN
COLORADO.
REPUBLICAN LEADER BRIAN DAHLE
AYE.
TO JOIN ME AT THE CENTER AISLE
TO RECEIVE OUR HONOREES.
WE'RE MOVING TO THE INTRODUCTION
OF THE UNSUNG HEROES FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
JANA REFORM A SIXTY SECOND
DISTRICT IS MISS KAREN EARLS SHE
IS ESCORTED BY SOME REMEMBER
BURKE.
KAREN EARLS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF GENESIS THE CENTER
INCORPORATED. IT IS THE OLDEST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION PROGRAM IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES AND IS RECOGNIZED AS
A FIRST SHELTER FOUNDED BY
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN WHO ARE
THEMSELVES SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
MS EARL HAS BEEN ELECTED TO THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE AGAINST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND WAS
APPOINTED TO THE STATE DOMESTIC
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. BY SIMPLY
SPEAKER HERB WESSON WELCOME
CAROL
.
WHERE ARE YOU FROM A NICE
DISTRICT IS MISCIBLE
SHARECROPPERS SHE IS ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER COOPER?
WE SHOT ROBERSON TO SEE AN
FOUNDER OF SAC CULTURAL HUB DOT
COM THE PREMIER LEADING SOURCE
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN SEARCHING
FOR URBAN ENTERTAINMENT NEWS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH AT CELEBRATE SIXTEEN YEARS
OF BUSINESS AS THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN IN SACRAMENTO TO ESTABLISH
A MULTI TIERED MIGHT ALREADY
WANT WOMAN OWNED MEDIA
ENTERPRISE. THE WEBSITE PROVIDES
AN INTERNET PLATFORM FOR VARIETY
OF MULTICULTURAL EVENTS CAREER
PROFILES AND THERE'S PEOPLE AND
BUSINESS SERVICES WEBSITE
CURRENTLY RECEIVES OVER TWO
MILLION HITS EACH MONTH. WELCOME
PLACE THAT ROBERTSON
.
THE ARE REALLY FROM THE SIXTY
FOURTH DISTRICT AS MISS PAMELA
BOARD SHE IS ESCORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER GIPSON.
PAMELA THORTON AS AN ADVOCATE
PREPARE LAND USE OPERATIONS
SHE HAS OVER FIFTEEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE GOD IN LAND USE
PLANNING ENTITLEMENT ZONING
OPERATIONS UTILIZING ECONOMIC
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CONCEPTS.
SHE REMAINS FOCUSED ISSUES AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE HARBOR
GATEWAY NORTH COMMUNITY
SHE RECENTLY PARTNER WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON ONLY GREEN
EDUCATION EVENT.
PAMELA CURRENTLY SERVES AS CHAIR
OF THE HARBOR GATEWAY NORTH
NORTH NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL WORKS
WITH CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN EDISON
AND WAS APPOINTED TO THE SIXTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMISSION BY SOME
REMEMBER MIKE A GIPSON EARLY IN
TWO
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WELCOME
PAMELA THORTON
.
BUT OUR REFORM THE FIFTY NINTH
THIS BECAUSE DOCTOR JOSEPH
BENJAMIN HEARTBREAK IS ESCORTED
BY SOME REMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
DOCTOR JOSEPH BENJAMIN HEART
RATE IS A SENIOR PASTOR PRAISES
EXILE MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH
IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. AFTER
THE WATTS WIDELY FOUND THE
PERSONAL INVOLVEMENT CENTER
WHICH PROVIDES VITAL SERVICES TO
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR HARPER TO SERVE IN THE
NATIONAL BAPTIST CONVENTION USA
INCLUDING AS PRESIDENT OF THE
WESTERN BAPTIST STATE
CONVENTION.
PRESIDENT HARDWICK IMPLEMENTED
CHARITABLE DRIVES STARTED TO J.
BENJAMIN HARPER SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM IN INTRODUCED A MEMORIAL
FUND TO ASSIST FAMILIES DOOR THE
LOSS OF A LOVED ONE.
WELCOME DOCTOR JOSEPH BENJAMIN
HARPER
.
BUT OUR REFORM THE FIFTEENTH
DISTRICT AS MISTER ARNOLD
PERKINS IS ESCORTED BY SOME
REPAIRMEN.
ARNOLD IS A FORMER IRECTOR OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. HE IS AN EXPERIENCED
SPEAKER AND FACILITATOR OF AREAS
OR OF ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
CONFLICT RESOLUTION TEAM
BUILDING CREATIVE LEADERSHIP
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND GROUP
DYNAMICS
THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT WORKERS
SUPPORT AND WITH THE HELP EQUITY
FOUNDERS AWARD FOR LIFETIME OF
INSPIRED VISION. PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
HEALTH EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE WAS
NAY BE SALZBURG GLOBAL FELLOW
FORCE WORKING BUILDING CAMINO.
WELCOME AREN'T WORKERS
.
THE ON A REEF FROM THE SEVENTY
NINTH THIS BECAUSE DOCTOR JOE
JOHN E. WARNED HE IS ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER WEBER. DOCTOR
WARNED US PRESIDENT OF WARNER
COMMUNICATIONS INCORPORATED AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN OWNED MEDIA
GROUP WITH COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS
ON THE EAST AND WEST COASTS.
HE WAS A WEEKLY COMMENTATOR ON
THE LOCAL NPR PBS STATION FOR
ALMOST A DECADE AND SERVED AS
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
DOCTOR WARREN HAS AN EXTENSIVE
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
INCLUDING TWELVE YEARS CONGRESS
AS IN WASHINGTON DC BOARD OF
EDUCATION MEMBER. AND AS
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION
HE HAS ALSO SERVED AS AN ELECTED
DELEGATE TO THE DEMOCRATIC
RETURN BRIDGING FROM WASHINGTON
DC. DURING THE CARTER PRESIDENCY
WELCOME DOCTOR JOHN MORE
.
GONNA REFORM A SEVENTH THIS
WOULD DISMISS CAN EFFECT BE ME
SHE IS ESCORTED BY SOME WOMEN
BEHOLDEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
CAN YOU FACT MAYBE IS THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH AND WELL
BEING INCORPORATED WHERE SHE IS
PLAYED A LEADING ROLE IN
DEVELOPING AGENCIES BLACK
MOTHERS UNITED PROGRAM.
WHICH SEEKS TO DECREASE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE WHICH
AFRICAN AMERICAN IF
TO DIE.
DURING THE MISSION DURING THE
INITIAL PROGRAM YEAR SHE WAS ONE
OF TO PERSONAL ADVOCATES
PROVIDING ONE ONE MENTOR
SHIPMENTS WERE SHIPPED EDUCATION
SUPPORT PREGNANT WOMEN.
EXCEEDING PROGRAM GOALS AND
ULTIMATELY SECURING A THREE YEAR
CONTRACT FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION IN FIRST FIVE GRANT
FUNDING. HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
INCLUDE CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING CREATION OF THE BABY
BECAUSE SEEK AND DEVELOPING
PARTNERSHIPS WELCOME CAN IN FACT
BE ME
.
THE HONOREE FROM A FIFTY FOURTH
DISTRICT IS MS JIMMY WOODS GRADE
SHE IS ESCORTED BY SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE JIMMY
WHAT'S GREAT BEGAN HER JOURNEY
AS AN EARLY CHILDHOOD TEACHER
AND THE LA U. S. D. CHILDREN
CENTER AND LATER BEGAN TEACHING
AT THE TWENTY FOUR SUITE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHERE SHE
WORKED FOR OVER THIRTY TWO
YEARS.
SHE JOINED HELD OFFICES WITH THE
UNITED TEACHERS LOS ANGELES
SERVING ABOARD DIRECTORS FOR THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
AND SERVE AS A DELEGATE TO OTHER
LABOR CAN CONVENTIONS
JIMMY WAS THE FIRST PERSON OF
COLOR EVER ELECTED AS
CHAIRPERSON OF THE LA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
AND ONLY THE SECOND WOMAN EVER
ELECTED JIMMY WHAT'S GREAT
RETIRE FROM LA U. S. D. ON JULY
ONE TWENTY ELEVEN AND CONTINUES
TO BE AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. WELCOME JIMMY WHAT'S
GREAT
.
THE ARE REASON FORTY FIRST
DISTRICT OR MR AND MRS JO WOULD
REPEAT HAWKINS.
THERE WAS SUPPORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER HOLDEN SHOWN REPEAT
HAWKINS CO OWNER PUBLISHER ST
PASSED.
THE PASADENA SAN GABLE VALLEY
JOURNAL NEWS THE ONLY AIR THE
AREA'S ONLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
OWNED ORIENTED NEWSPAPER ADS
SAYING IT WILL BALLOTS SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
THE JOURNAL COVERS EIGHT CITIES
FORTY THOUSAND READERS EACH
WEEK.
BEGAN FROM A LACK OF NEWSPAPER
IN THE AREA FOR BLACK FOR BLACKS
TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS COUPLE
QUICKLY REALIZE THAT THE
NEWSPAPER WAS A TOOL TO ADDRESS
SERIOUS ISSUES AGAIN SARGE. FACE
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THE ISSUES
THEY TACKLE INCLUDE
DISCRIMINATION LACK OF DIVERSITY
INEQUALITY AND LACK OF
REPRESENTATION AT THE SET AT THE
PASADENA ROSE BOWL. PASADENA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE CITY
OF PASADENA AN ADVERTISING
INEQUALITY AT THE PASADENA
PLAYHOUSE
BECAUSE OF THE INFLUENCE OF THE
SAN DIEGO VALLEY JOURNAL
TOURNAMENT OF ROSES WILL HAVE
ITS FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
WELCOME JOE WOULD REPEAT HAWKINS
.
WE'RE CAUCUSES ALSO RECOGNIZING
ON A REASON THE SENATE WRITTEN
GRADUATE THE HONORABLE ROBERT
FARRELL AND MR T!I REPORT
PATES WERE FROM THE THIRTY FIFTH
AND THIRTY A SENATE DISTRICTS
REPRESENT BY SENATORS BRADFORD
AND MITCHELL
SENATOR THERE HAS NOT BEEN IN
MOTION FOR YOU TO ACTUALLY
SPEAK.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
FOR THE FLOOR CEREMONY TODAY AND
THE BREAKFAST RECEPTION
YESTERDAY.
MOURNING AND CELEBRATING WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN DR KING'S EIGHTY
NINTH BIRTHDAY.
TO BUILD UPON THIS YEAR'S THEME
BLACK VOICES RECLAIMING OUR
INFLUENCE OUR KEYNOTE SPEAKER
DONNA BRAZILE. DELIVERED
UNFORGETTABLE ADDRESS.
AS MOMENTO AND AN AUTOGRAPHED
COPY. OF HER LATEST BOOK WILL BE
PROVIDED TO ALL OF THE MEMBERS.
THE NEXT MONTH WE WILL
COMMEMORATE THIS CENTENNIAL.
OF THE ELECTION OF THE FIRST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN PERSON ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
THE HONORABLE FREDERICK ROBERTS.
WE ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A
FEW MOMENTS TO VIEW THE EXHIBIT.
ON THE SECOND FLOOR.
ROTUNDA AT YOUR LEISURE.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY AS
OUR HONOREES ARE EXITING THE
CHAMBER JOIN ME AT ANOTHER ROUND
OF APPLAUSE.
FOR HONORING
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OF SIX SIX
SIX
THE SIX THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS AND TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE WITH AMENDMENT.
ALL AMENDMENTS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND COMMITTEE REPORTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
WE'RE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE COOK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SOME A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC LAND IN CONSERVATION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RULE IN
THE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO A GERMAN
TO MEMORY.
AND ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
DOCTOR CHOI FOR A SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT.
DOCTOR CHOI.
NOW SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS SIDE.
I AM SO HAPPY.
TO ANNOUNCE I BECAME A GRANDPA.
MY JOB VOTERS.
.
SON.
A MASON CHIANG HAS ARRIVED THE
JANUARY A. VERY HEALTHY. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE.
MY FIRST.
CONGRATULATIONS DOCTOR TOY.
SEEING NO FURTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS PUBLIC SAFETY WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN. ALMOST
HOPE.
ALL MOTION CHUBBY CONTINUED THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
MONDAY JANUARY FIFTEENTH AS A
HOLIDAY FOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR.
DAY JANUARY SIXTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
FORM BECAUSE LIFTED WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN SOME MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR THE GERMAN AND MEMORIES.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU KNOW WHO REMEMBERS.
THIS MORNING I AM DURING IN
MEMORY OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSIONER
CAROLE DELIA A SACRAMENTO.
CAROL IS A LONGTIME ACTIVIST IN
THE GREEN HAVEN POCKET
NEIGHBORHOOD IN OUR CHURCH AT
SENTENCING ANTHONY'S PARISH.
SHE THE COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER AND
ORGANIZER BEFORE SHE WAS HIRED
BY LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE.
CHU UNDERSERVED THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR COMING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
CAROL IS A DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT.
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH THREE MONTHS
AFTER BEING DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER.
TO FIVE YEARS OLD. CAROLYN JOYCE
THE OUTDOORS JUST RETURNED FROM
A TRIP TO YELLOWSTONE NATIONAL
PARK.
WHICH WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER.
KILLED SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
JON DAUGHTER AMANDA.
SON ADAM DELIA ALL SACRAMENTO
MY HEARTFELT PRAYERS GO OUT TO
DELIA FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
SHOULD BE DEEPLY MISSED.
THE FEE OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER MS
MELENDEZ YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
NOVEMBER FIRST TO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN MY COMMUNITY LOST A
WONDERFUL MAN MARTIN SYLVAN
GALVIN WAS BORN AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY.
TODAVA MATILDA GAL BAND IN
BROOKLYN NEW YORK HE GRADUATED
FROM BROOKLYN COLLEGE AND THEN
WENT ON TO ADD LIST IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE.
AFTER SERVING HIS COUNTRY HE
RETURNED HOME AS A DISABLED
VETERAN OF THE KOREAN WAR HE
LATER WENT ON TO PURSUE A CAREER
IN MARKETING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THERE HE LIVED
OUT THE REMAINDER HIS YEARS IN
MENIFEE WITH HIS WIFE PAM LINUS
TWO LITTLE DOGS.
MARTY WAS A PROUD AND A PROUD
VETERAN A STEADFAST PETRI TO HIS
COUNTRY. I'M AN EXTREMELY LOYAL
TO THE CORE HE WAS EXTREMELY
ACTIVE IN MY COMMUNITY
PARTICULAR WITH THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY AND MOST RECENTLY
BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY WITH THE
SENIOR ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT I
HAD FORMED.
AND I WILL PERSONALLY MRS
UNFORGETTABLE BOLD FACED RED
FINDS.
ALL IN CAPS EMAILS THAT HE WOULD
SEND TO ME ON A WEEKLY BASIS AB
DISCUSSING WHATEVER ISSUE THAT
HE HAD A NATION THAT HE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH THAT DAY.
BUT HE ALWAYS HAD A SOLUTION TO
GO ALONG WITH WITH THE PROBLEM
THAT HE WAS THAT BRINGING TO
LIGHT. IT WAS AN HONOR TO BE IS
REPRESENTATIVE AND IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I ASKED TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MS MELINDA'S.
MISTER PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER UP.
ALONG WITH. MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMAN FRANK BIGELOW. I'M I
RISE TODAY TO UP RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
OF A HUMBLE LEGEND WHO REALLY
WAS LARGER THAN LIFE.
BUT WILBUR PLUGGER WAS A
RENOWNED ENTERTAINER. HE WAS
KNOWN AS THE GREATEST LIVING
COWBOY BY MANY. AND WAS OFTEN
COMPARED TO JOHN WAYNE. HE STOOD
SIX FOOT FOUR INCH HE WAS A BULL
RIDER A RODEO CHAMPION. AND WAS
EVEN A RODEO CLOWN HE WAS ALSO
AN ACTOR.
BUT HE STARTED HIS.
CAREER AT THE CLOVIS RODEO IN
NINETEEN FORTY.
WHEN ONE OF THE BULL RIDERS
DIDN'T SHOW UP. HE VOLUNTEERED
AND NEVER LOOKED BACK.
WILBUR WAS INDUCTED INTO ALMOST
A DOZENRODEO HALLS OF FAME
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
HE PLEDGED TO NEVER RETIRE AND
ONCE SAID IF EVER HE COULDN'T
GET ON A HORSE ON HIS OWN. HE'D
GET A LADDER.
HE WAS AT HOME ON A HORSE BUT HE
WAS ALSO MUCH AT HOME IN THE
PULPIT HE WAS A WINSOME WITNESS
OF HIS FAITH. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE HE CO FOUNDED THE
FELLOWSHIP OF CHRISTIAN COWBOYS.
AND LED COWBOY CHURCH SERVICES.
WILBUR PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
SECOND.
NINETY FIVE SURELY.
A LIFE VERY WELL LIVED.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
NEARLY SEVENTY YEARS ROOF.
FOR CHILDREN NINE GRANDCHILDREN
AND NINETEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
AYE HIS FUNERAL SERVICES AND
GRAVESIDE SERVICES ARE TODAY IN
FRESNO THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MR CALDERON MOVES TO MR ALDRIN
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY JANUARY
SIXTEENTH AT ONE PM QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED